hello everybody producer pat ford here
filling in for david pakman on another
exciting edition of the david pakman
show fear not david is going to be back
on monday but for today at least on this
christmas eve edition of the show you
are all stuck with me but that's okay
because we're going to talk about a lot
of interesting stuff we're going to talk
about build back better we're going to
talk about joe manchin we're going to
talk about omicron and the latest covet
surge so let's get right into the news
as we know this week joe manchin
effectively killed the build back better
legislation in its current forum the 1.9
trillion dollar social spending plan is
not going to get passed this year and
it's not going to get passed in its
current form uh mansion went on fox news
sunday with brett bear and he told him
look i'm just not going to support this
thing so as of now it's dead in the
water chief among mansion's reasons for
opposing the bill were that he believed
it would add to the national debt he
believed it would further accelerate the
rate of inflation in the united states
and he just gave this general sentiment
of look we're we're spending so much
money as it is right now we can't
possibly afford to spend any more so
some of this economic fear-mongering
stuff that we will often hear from the
centrists and the right wing of this
country of course depending on the
circumstances well goldman sachs ran the
numbers and they found that actually not
passing buildback better is going to
cost the us economy money because the
spending plan would infuse 60 billion
dollars into the gross domestic product
a team of economists at goldman
predicted that the us gdp would grow
three percent in the first quarter of
2022 if buildback better were passed 3.5
percent in the second quarter and
another three percent in the third
quarter of 2022 that's again if
buildback better was signed into law
this year now the estimate uh without
the spending plan in place because they
redid the numbers uh is that two percent
uh is going to be the rate of growth for
the first quarter three percent is going
to be the rate of growth for the second
quarter and 2.75
in the third quarter of 2022 and when
you line up all of those numbers you
compare the percentages you run the raw
numbers the differences add up to 60
billion dollars in economic losses for
the first three quarters of 2022 and of
course it's probably going to add up to
a lot more than that because it's only
counting for the first three quarters of
the year and obviously the impacts of
buildback better are going to extend far
beyond 2022 now of course we have to
include some caveats here like for
example just because we're not going to
get the 1.9 trillion dollar legislation
there's a good chance that we get
something done right i mean maybe it'll
be 500 billion maybe it'll be a trillion
maybe it'll be 1.5 trillion dollars we
just don't yet know what the total is
going to be and we don't know what
provisions are going to get passed yet
and unfortunately it seems to be really
up to mansion and what he wants to do
but we'll probably see some boost to the
gdp numbers compared to those more
conservative estimates second of all you
can never fully predict what the us
economy is going to do sometimes we hear
estimates from financial institutions or
government agencies about what we expect
job numbers to be or what we expect the
stock market to be at months down the
line years down the line and it's always
just a guess i mean you can make an
educated guess certainly but you never
know until it actually happens you can't
fully predict the us economy and what
it's going to do but these estimates
certainly do seem to jive with the
reality of the economy and what we know
about demand side stimulus because if
you think about it if you go to these
different provisions on the bill
one of the key provisions is extending
the child tax credit of three thousand
dollars or three thousand six hundred
dollars depending on the age of the
child uh per year um per child it works
out so that if people have this extra
money in their pocket they're going to
be able to spend it on things like going
out to dinner or going on vacation or
birthday presents or whatever the case
may be and the same can be said about
the other provisions too right because
people can save some money on the cost
of elder care or child care or
healthcare costs or prescription drug
costs and so with that extra money
people can go out and participate in the
economy and it can be economically
stimulative so i understand why this
conservative argument will sometimes win
the day because it just seems so
intuitive right like if we just don't
spend the money that means that we're
going to save the money but it's
actually quite the opposite and that's
exactly what these goldman sachs numbers
show us
and we of course know that republicans
are going to make this argument we know
that they love to fear fearmonger about
inflation and spending and the debt and
the deficit of course they only do that
when a democrat is in charge they don't
care so much about these things when a
republican is in the white house we saw
that last year with donald trump
compared to joe biden this year i mean
these these things like inflation and
spending they were all going on under
the trump administration last year only
now do they care about these things but
what's upsetting is that someone who is
supposed to be a democrat joe manchin he
also buys into these talking points and
ultimately that's going to harm the
people of west virginia and it's going
to harm the country as a whole because
it's going to cost the us economy
billions of dollars going into next year
vermont senator bernie sanders you know
him you love him he is not giving up on
buildback better just because joe
manchin is giving up on it and in fact
bernie is ready to bring the fight to
joe manchin and bring it to manchin's
home state of west virginia i think it's
easy for some of us to say well look we
have a 50 50 senate right now and shucks
what are we going to do you have the
split control and democrats we're not
going to get everything that we want
because you have to appeal to the most
conservative members of the party like
your joe manchins and your kirsten
cinemas so ultimately we'll get some
stuff that we want but not everything
well bernie is just saying i'm not going
to take that approach i'm going to stand
in the way here and i'm going to do so
by making sure that west virginia voters
know exactly why they can't get all of
these different favorable provisions
like the child tax credit and the elder
and child care and universal preschool
and so much more and they can't get all
that stuff because of their own senator
democrat joe manchin bernie went on
cnn's state of the union this week with
jake tapper and he proposed the idea of
cnn paying for a poll asking residents
what they think of all the different
components of buildback better and then
as he thought about it he said you know
what screw it i'm going to pay for the
damn poll let's take a look at the video
if senator manchin were here he would
say
my
state is a state that voted
overwhelmingly for donald trump what i'm
doing and going after and opposing this
legislation will be popular and manchin
has said he thinks
all this money he's saying all this
money is going to be
going to make inflation worse
i thought well let me talk about joe
manchin voted for a huge increase in
military spending manchester voted for
an infrastructure bill which added 250
billion dollars to the deficit
the truth of the matter is that if you
look at the military budget 770 billion
times that by 10 years it is four times
higher than what the build back better
plan is
now you know mr manches says he's
representing the people of west virginia
okay why don't you do a poll it's cnn do
a poll and you ask the people of west
virginia whether or not they want to
lower the cost of prescription drugs you
ask them whether they want to expand
medicare to cover dental hearing and
eyeglasses you ask whether they want to
continue the 300 payment to help working
parents in these very difficult times
bring up their kids with dignity ask
them if they want to deal with climate
change on all of those issues i suspect
people of west virginia like every other
state in this country will say yes do
the right thing for working families is
there and i challenge
you know i told mansion by the way i'll
pay for the damn poll in west virginia
on those issues see how the people of
west virginia feel i like that so bernie
sanders he wrote the damn bill having to
do with medicare for all and now he'll
pay for the damn poll having to do with
build back better so bernie is really
getting assertive there and of course
bernie is right now if you asked voters
in conservative trump supporting west
virginia do you support joe biden's 1.9
trillion dollar social spending plan
you're probably not going to get
favorable results i doubt you'd get 50
support just being honest there that's
the reality but like what bernie points
out if you go provision by provision
and you ask people do you support
lowering prescription drug prices do you
support expanding medicare do you
support a child tax credit and all these
different things of course people are
going to say yes to all those different
things because they are indeed popular
and it doesn't matter whether you ask
people in liberal california or
conservative west virginia people are
going to say that they like all of that
different stuff this is by the way
exactly what we saw when it came to the
affordable care act years ago if you
polled people back then and you said
okay do you want people young people to
be able to stay on their parents health
care coverage until they turn 26 people
would say yes if you ask people whether
or not they think that businesses with
more than 50 employees should be able to
should have to offer health insurance to
their workers people would say yes and
if you ask people whether or not they
think that health insurance companies
should be able to deny coverage to
discriminate based on pre-existing
conditions people would say no but then
if you said okay well do you support
obamacare people would say no i don't
perhaps not realizing that the aca did
all of those different things so bernie
is exactly right here that a poll
conducted in west virginia on all the
different build back better provisions
it would probably do really well there
but it of course depends on how you ask
the questions and this is also not the
first time that bernie has tried to
pressure joe manchin in this way and
it's not even the first time that he's
tried to do it on buildback better
specifically a couple of months ago
bernie wrote an op-ed in the charleston
gazette mail which is a west virginia
based newspaper and he argued for the
social spending bill which back then was
actually more like three trillion
dollars it's a lot smaller now because
democrats caved to the most conservative
members of their party like mansion
cinema and they reduced it by about a
trillion dollars at the time it was a
lot bigger and it seems like bernie
writing that op-ed really got under joe
manchin's skin and he said it was
because well we have this out-of-stater
telling us what we should do here in
west virginia but i think it really
truly got under joe manchin's skin
because he knew that bernie sanders was
right here and this is what we got to do
this is playing hardball and it's
exactly what bernie should be doing
biden should be doing the exact same
thing do some speeches in west virginia
meet with people there talk about how
buildback better would materially
improve their lives get on the phone
with joe manchin's office obviously you
keep it respectful and you give manchin
the room to change his mind with some
dignity but make it clear that his job
security could be put at risk if he
decides not to support the legislation
okay one more story having to do with
joe manchin killing the build back
better legislation this week we have to
talk about how the squad was actually
proven right and centrist democrats were
proven wrong at least when it comes to
one important aspect of all this a few
weeks ago
when the physical infrastructure deal
was being debated there were several
members of congress the progressive
democrats specifically who urged house
speaker nancy pelosi and senate majority
leader chuck schumer to couple the
infrastructure deal with the
multi-trillion dollar spending bill
build back better and indeed for a few
weeks those two bills were coupled
together and the idea was that manchin
and some of these other centrist
democrats they're sure yeses on physical
infrastructure they definitely want to
see that get passed but when it comes to
the multi-trillion dollar spending plan
we just can't trust them they seem to be
changing their minds and you know we
just don't know if they're sure yeses
eventually nancy pelosi decided to cave
to the moderates in the party and uh
they decided to separate the two bills
and biden gave her the stamp of approval
to do so saying that we're going to be
able to assure that joe manchin is going
to vote yes on both pieces of
legislation so
joe biden he essentially gave us his
word on that but the squad they weren't
buying it so when it came time to
actually vote on the infrastructure deal
in november most of the congressional
progressive caucus they decided to vote
yes that's pramila jayapal katie porter
ro khanna and a bunch of other familiar
names but the
the six squad members they held firm and
they voted no that's jamal bowman corey
bush alexandria ocasio-cortez ilhan omar
ayana presley and rashida talip and they
voted no not because they don't want to
see infrastructure get passed that's
actually quite the opposite they
definitely are in support of revamping
american infrastructure but they viewed
this as the best bargaining chip that
they had for making sure that both of
the bills got past the physical
infrastructure and the so-called human
infrastructure
and at the time there was a sentiment
among many democrats that was like look
let's get infrastructure done biden
hasn't had a significant legislative
achievement in a while maybe not since
the covid stimulus plan was passed back
in march
and we also don't know if we're going to
be able to in the long term maintain
this 60 vote threshold that we need in
the senate to get this passed because
you really can't trust republicans like
maybe they'll decide they don't want to
support this thing anymore the idea was
let's get it done now we'll get this
round of positive press coverage about
the infrastructure deal and then before
the end of the year we'll get buildback
better done through budget
reconciliation and that will prompt
another round of positive media coverage
and it'll be viewed as yet another
accomplishment for joe biden and the
democrats obviously that didn't play out
and the squad was right to question
manchin's willingness to go along with
the rest of the party we actually have a
video now of camila jayapal talking to
many hassan about everything that went
on and she maintains that she has no
regrets in all of this but i i sort of
doubt that let's take a look at the
video and then we'll come back how do
you feel about that today do you feel
that joe biden let you down and do you
feel you got played by joe manchin
no and no um we are you know for the
weeks and the days going up to the vote
in the house everybody every day if i
had counted i would be if i got a penny
for every time somebody said to me this
is not to happen you all have given up
everything we got it done in the house
now i am in the same place in saying
that we are getting grenades rolled at
us all the time we have to pick them up
we have to put the pin back in and we
have to continue to focus on the fact
that this is going to be rocky we can't
hang our you know our commitments and
our hopes on the words of one senator or
two senators we have to continue to work
to get it done and the vast majority of
it is done and so i was on the phone
with
senator schumer today with the white
house and i believe we will still get it
done it's going to be rocky and we just
have to continue to leave no space in
the
in the commitment to getting it done and
listen the president's word is on the
line here and i do still believe that he
is going to do what he told me and what
he told our caucus and what he told the
country he would do
had we not done what we had done
and if he doesn't congresswoman
what was that
and if he doesn't
no we're going to do it we're going to
do it and the leverage that you had your
critics would argue was lost when you
voted for biff i just wonder do you
regret voting for the biff deal now in
hindsight given it's now months later
and joe manchin is nowhere closer to
signing off on 1.75 trillion
no i don't regret it because i think our
leverage was at the maximum point on the
other side of the coin we have one of
the squad members aoc tweeting about
this saying quote when a handful of us
in the house warned this would happen if
democratic leaders gave manchin
everything he wanted first by moving
biff that's the bipartisan
infrastructure framework before
buildback better instead of passing
together many ridiculed our position
maybe they'll believe us next time or
maybe people will just keep calling us
naive and unfortunately given the
establishment democrats track record on
all of this and when it comes to them
trying to listen to progressives it'll
probably be the second one of those two
options there uh and they'll probably
just keep getting called naive but there
is a counter argument to all of this
that we have to consider as well and it
is a strong one which is that even if
the entire progressive caucus held firm
and they prevented the infrastructure
deal from getting passed in the house
and they made sure that it was only
going to happen in one piece of
legislation the two bills had to be put
together and that was it are we sure
that joe manchin would have actually
voted for it like the argument is that
he would right because he supports the
infrastructure deal and west virginia
desperately needs new infrastructure but
he just as easily could have done the
same exact thing here he could have said
you know i like some pieces of this
legislation i like the infrastructure
stuff but there are members of my party
who are trying to poison pill it with
all this other nonsense and there was
this opportunity to make this bill
bipartisan and the progressives are
ruining that opportunity so i just can't
support this bill in any form that also
could have happened that also is a
legitimate possibility and then
progressives at the end of the day they
look bad because they are the ones who
are blamed for not allowing
infrastructure to pass when even some
centrist republicans are willing to do
it and you have the remainder of the
democratic party in support of it so
what we know for now is that the squad
was definitely right not to trust joe
manchin not to trust his word because
his word means nothing but whether or
not we actually would have been able to
get both of these things passed by the
end of the year that remains uncertain
and to be honest i guess we'll never
truly know it's sort of unfalsifiable in
a sense because it really just comes
down to what joe manchin is thinking on
any particular day and that's
unfortunately what we have to deal with
so that's everything having to do with
buildback better as of now we're going
to go to a break
back after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
welcome back to the david pakman show
i'm producer pat ford here filling in
for david on this christmas eve david is
traveling right now he's on vacation in
southern california having a good time
and he is going to be back with us on
monday you know it's been a little while
since we gave a cobid update on the show
and i thought that given the latest
surge that we're seeing in infections it
would be good to provide you with one
today obviously much of this latest
surge has to do with the omicron variant
which we first heard about only a month
ago hard to believe uh and since it came
from south africa in such a short amount
of time it has been able to become the
dominant strain here in the u.s with an
estimated 70 to 80 percent of current
cases being attributed to the variant of
course the speculation when it comes to
omicron is that it's a lot more
contagious yes but not nearly as severe
that less severe part we're not totally
sure about we'll know for sure hopefully
in the next couple of weeks or so i'm
going to talk more about that later but
let's take a look at the case chart
looking at the case chart back in the
spring of 2020 we had what looks like a
tiny wave there which is actually
deceptive because it was hard to come by
tests during that time the numbers were
probably a lot more crazy than the graph
shows but of course these are confirmed
cases we had this wave in the spring of
2020 and then we got a small wave in the
summer of 2020 mainly because of places
like texas and florida there were places
like new england at that time that were
doing just fine but there were other
parts of the country not doing so well
in the summer of 2020 then by the winter
of 2020 into 2021 we had this just out
of control giant spike topping out at
about 250 000 to 300 000 cases per day
but then as the weather warmed up and
more importantly as people got
vaccinated because this is the time that
vaccines became available we went back
to super low numbers and many of us
thought that in may june july of this
year that this all could be over with
soon but then we got into the late
summer there was another wave then which
calmed down by october and now
unfortunately we're heading back up
seeing about 150 000-ish new cases a day
and the question is how high are we
going to go retiring nih director
francis collins is predicting that
things could get as bad here as 1
million new cases a day 1 million
and that's just based on how contagious
omicron is now looking at the death
numbers we're seeing a slight uptick so
far from the october valley getting
around 1500 deaths a day but as we know
deaths tend to lag cases by a few weeks
so
are we not seeing a major surge yet in
the death numbers because omicron isn't
nearly as deadly or is it because just
not enough time has passed yet and
because people are getting infected with
it now we could possibly see the surge
in deaths in the next couple of weeks we
just don't know yet another key point is
that even if we do find omicron to be
less deadly than previous strains that's
not going to help us all that much if
we're seeing a million cases a day like
even if the rate is somewhat low if
we're seeing that many cases there's
still going to be thousands and
thousands of people who die from this
every single day and it could be just as
bad overall as the big wave that we saw
in the winter of last year so that's one
important thing to consider now
obviously we know that vaccination is
our best way to protect against
infection but especially against severe
cobit and death and that's why some
cities are joining cities like new york
and los angeles and now requiring proof
of vaccination to do into our activities
and also uh because of omicron we're
seeing some cancellations that we
arguably haven't seen since the start of
the pandemic so let me run through you a
list of cancellations that we've seen
over the past week or so
and i'm sure that this list is going to
be added to over the coming days
broadway shows have now closed their
doors through christmas week the ball
drop in times square will go on but it's
going to be scaled back with masks
required for those in attendance the
world economic forum scheduled for davos
switzerland has been postponed until the
summer i'm sure most
many other conferences will follow soon
companies shutting their doors to
non-essential workers include cnn apple
google uber lyft and ford universities
that shut down their campuses early for
the remainder of the semester included
cornell nyu and princeton and then in
terms of travel uh israel france and the
netherlands closed their borders to more
countries and added more travel
restrictions when it comes to sports the
nfl decided to move some games around
the nba decided to postpone a few of
their games in the nhl as maybe being
the most strict they decided to put a
pause on games until after christmas and
also they've decided to pull out of the
winter olympics in beijing china because
of the surge so we'll have to wait and
see whether or not these decisions make
sense i think the sentiment is well
you'd rather be safe than sorry let's
see if cases reach a peak anytime soon
and if they do reach a peak let's see
where that peak exactly is but the
numbers right now they're just not going
in the right direction and what worries
us especially now is that we're about to
see families get together for christmas
we're about to see friends get together
for new year's celebrations and so
there's definitely a whole lot of
reasons to be cautious now about omicron
and covet in general so to recap the
omicron variant is now wreaking havoc
throughout the us and the rest of the
world and we're now seeing at least a
hundred thousand new cases of covid
every single day here in the u.s with
estimates showing that it could get a
lot worse but there are some people
suggesting that there's no reason to
worry because yes while omicron is quite
contagious and we may see a lot of
infections it's not going to be very
deadly we're not going to see a big
spike in the death numbers and the
evidence that people base that off of is
the fact that we have this data out of
south africa where the variant is
believed to have originated and it just
wasn't all that deadly there well
there's this great piece now in npr
highlighting that what we saw in south
africa may not exactly match up with
what we're going to see here in the u.s
we certainly hope that it does we
certainly hope that there's not this big
spike in the death numbers but we just
we don't know for sure we can't exactly
bank on that a study out of south africa
with 200 000 coded positive participants
about a quarter of whom had serious
underlying health conditions was
underway between september and november
of this year so that's the tail end of
the delta wave along with the beginning
of the omicron wave researchers found
that as time went on and omicron became
dominant there was a 30 percent drop in
hospitalizations from this pool of
people with the covet cases the rate of
hospitalization for omicron was quite
low is only 58 per 1000 which is the
lowest of the four coveted waves that
the country has experienced since this
all started two years ago hard to
believe it's been that long
not only that instances of patients
needing oxygen or ventilation dropped
and icu stays went down to only 13
percent from where it was at at 30 also
people recovered a lot quicker than in
the previous waves so there you go right
we're going to be just fine here well
maybe let's let's hold our horses here
because the key variable is that the
data did not take into account previous
exposure to the virus and many of these
cases were reinfections with south
africa believed to have a much higher
level of immunity than we have here in
the united states now the vaccination
rates in south africa they're quite a
bit lower only about one in four south
africans had been vaccinated by the time
that omicron hit but the vast majority
of residents in south africa had
so-called natural immunity having had a
previous
version of coronavirus so between
previous infections and the amount of
people who are vaccinated in south
africa there were just few people
statistically left who hadn't been
exposed to either the virus or the
vaccine
nearly everyone in this coveted pool
that they looked at had some version of
immunity and we know that when you get
covered for a second time or when you
get it after having been vaccinated
symptoms aren't nearly as bad the death
counts aren't nearly as bad and your
recovery time is generally a lot quicker
so key to understanding this may be to
figure out the number of people in the
u.s with no previous exposure to covid
or the vaccine and we'll have to see
we'll have to wait and see how this is
going to affect them as of now about 62
percent of americans have been
vaccinated fully vaccinated with the two
doses and an estimated 20 percent of
americans have been infected with covet
since the start of the pandemic it's
hard to believe it's only 20 you'd think
it'd be a lot higher than that number
now obviously there's going to be some
crossover between these two groups of
people because some people got
vaccinated and then later got a
breakthrough case of covet there's also
people who got covered early on and then
later got vaccinated so you can't just
like add up the two numbers and come up
with your your overall immunity number
but when you actually crunch the numbers
when you do it appropriately it turns
out that 20 percent of americans that's
66 million people have no immunity at
all and that leaves plenty of people who
could potentially get a serious case
depending really on how severe omicron
is and again we just don't know yet so
we can be optimistic about the variant
but we have to be cautiously optimistic
and the best way to do that is to
obviously observe the normal protocols
wear the mask socially distance get
vaccinated if you're eligible get the
booster shot if you can i just got my
booster shot a couple days ago wasn't
feeling so great yesterday but you know
i got over the side effects in about a
day or so do all the right things make
sure that we
don't
just throw caution to the wind here and
make sure that we observe the right
protocols and hopefully omicron doesn't
turn out to be so bad but we just don't
know for sure yet we're going to go to a
break we'll be back with much much more
on the david pakman show right after
this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show hey everybody producer
pat here bringing you some holiday cheer
on this christmas eve let's get back
into the news story starting with this
one about the 2024 presidential race a
new poll finds that a majority of
americans don't want to see donald trump
run for president again but also a
majority of americans they don't want to
see joe biden run for president again
either the poll comes to us from echelon
insights and the results are that 55 of
respondents don't want to see donald
trump seek the presidency again in 2024
and that's great news right but also
statistically just as many 54 of
respondents they say that they don't
want to see joe biden run again as well
now on the approval side when you flip
the question and ask do you want trump
to one run do you want biden to run
there does seem to be more support for
trump running than biden 39 give trump
the go-ahead whereas only 34 percent say
the same thing about biden so the
question is three years out from the
next presidential race is this cause for
concern for democrats i think part of
this is that americans are saying they
want to see new faces you know if trump
runs again this will be his third
attempt he's been non-stop in the
political atmosphere ever since 2015.
biden he's been in the senate forever
and then he was vice president he ran a
bunch of different presidential
campaigns and then of course now he is
the president so you know it's just time
to see some new people here we're sort
of sick of these guys and we don't want
to see an exact repeat of the 2020
election after all and part of this also
is the fact that they are quite up there
in age right if trump gets elected in
2024 he's going to be 78 by the time
he's elected and 82 by the time he
leaves office and if joe biden gets
re-elected he's going to be 82 at the
start of his second term and 86 by the
time that he's out of office and we know
that of course people now are living
longer lives these days and you can have
elderly people who are capable of doing
the job but some may say 80s that's kind
of pushing it maybe we need some younger
blood in there but i think this really
comes down to at the end of the day the
most important factor in all of this is
that the hardcore trump people who make
up somewhere between 35 to 40
unfortunately of the country they want
him no matter what right they don't care
about ted cruz they don't care about
nikki haley you know maybe ron desantis
is okay but only as a backup option if
trump doesn't want to run um and so
that's i think why we're seeing the
numbers show that 39 of people say they
do want trump to run those are the
hardcore trump supporters whereas
there's people who support joe biden but
they don't have the same sort of cult of
personality uh view of him right biden
doesn't have this sort of
appeal that trump does among his base of
supporters uh biden's approval rating
right now is in the low to mid 40s which
is not great it's also not terrible but
the number who wants to see him run
again is uh again 34 which is
substantially lower than what his
approval number's at so that suggests to
me that there's a good amount of people
who are saying yeah i like what biden's
doing but he's replaceable right like if
you give us kamala harris if you give us
pete budge or elizabeth warren or
whoever else uh we'll like them too
because at the end of the day it's more
about the cause than the person and then
also in addition you don't have to worry
about the age factor you don't have to
worry about age or fitness or anything
like that so that's my takeaway the
trump people are wrapped up in the cult
of trump and the biden people don't care
about biden specifically they just want
to move the causes forward and i think
there's a real question whether biden
will run again mainly because of the age
factor i think that if he chooses not to
run again obviously there will be a
primary in the democratic field there's
a possibility that kamala harris being
the vice president she court she gets
that coronation treatment that hillary
clinton got back in 2016. hopefully that
doesn't happen and hopefully we get some
progressive challenges in there to um
make it not so easy of a fight for her
but ultimately if biden chooses to run
again he'll get the nomination
and i think trump is definitely running
again also i mean he's dropping all
these hints as to how he's going to
launch another campaign i know some
people like michael cohen for example
he's saying uh including on the show he
said i don't think that trump is going
to run again because he's terrified of
losing for a second time he doesn't want
to be seen as a two-time loser and the
excuse of voter fraud if he does lose
isn't going to work again but i just
don't buy that like first of all i think
that if trump does run again he's going
to have a substantial chance at winning
i think he's actually going to get
better odds of winning than he did in
2016 or 2020. and if he does lose then
he'll just tell his voters yeah it was
voter fraud and they're already primed
to believe the voter fraud stuff they'll
just say like okay well they got us
again those democrats rigging their
elections so you know i don't think
trump is really worried about anything
there it's sort of a heads i win tails
you lose sort of scenario where either
he wins the presidency or he just says
once again that he got cheated so the
bottom line is most americans don't want
to see trump run again most americans
don't want to see biden run again and
yet there's still a halfway decent shot
that we see yet another trump biden
match up a repeat of the last election
cycle in 2024 you know ever since we
started hearing about the labor shortage
situation here in the us there's been so
much blame to go around some people like
to blame lazy millennials other people
like to blame the joe biden
administration other people like to
blame poor people who are just unwilling
to go get a job and you know there's
been this idea that because of the
boosted unemployment benefits that meant
that many people were just one willing
to get a job they wanted to just stay
home and live off of government
resources the same was said about the
stimulus checks with the idea that okay
well if you get a thousand dollars here
and there you don't really need to work
which is kind of silly really because
obviously a thousand bucks or twelve
hundred bucks fourteen hundred dollars
that's not going to be enough to cover
your long-term basic needs and indeed
the labor shortage does persist the
number of job openings was at an
all-time high as of october at more than
11 million openings and companies are
struggling still to hire enough workers
to meet the demand but the truth is that
the labor shortage is caused by a
multitude of factors and chief among
them have to do with baby boomers
retiring early and a reduction in worker
visas that have been granted over the
course of the pandemic overall i was
able to come up with eight reasons in
total for the labor shortage situation
so i wanted to run through them all with
you here so number one and these are in
no particular order people are retiring
early estimates suggest that the us has
about two million more retirees right
now than we otherwise would have
expected if we had not had the pandemic
and this makes sense because let's say
you were 62 years old when the pandemic
started and you planned on retiring at
age 65 well by now you're about 63 and a
half going on 64. do you really want to
go back to work for another year or so
especially when you already are
semi-retired as it is probably not
especially given the fact that the stock
market has boomed over the past couple
of years so people's retirement accounts
are higher than they expected them to be
also real estate values have gone up
significantly so people assuming they
own their house and assuming they have a
401k or an ira uh they've seen a
sizeable growth in their wealth over the
past couple of years making it so they
may not have to keep working they might
as well just retire early number two has
to do with immigration the us government
has issued about 1.2 million fewer visas
to adult immigrants refugees and
temporary foreign workers and i think
this is intuitive given that
restrictions on travel were in existence
especially during the early phase of the
pandemic many of these restrictions
still exist today there's a chance also
that uh you know things can turn around
because now the department of homeland
security has announced that the biden
administration is going to be adding 20
000 new slots to a seasonal guest worker
program for the winter season but it
makes sense that given there's a
pandemic raging throughout the world
people just don't want to be traveling
from country to country number three
there's a skills mismatch 48 of workers
said that they were frustrated with the
search and 46 said that they can only
find low paying rules just because a job
is available that doesn't mean that
people necessarily want to take that job
it doesn't necessarily mean that it's a
good paying job and we know that some
people were able to take advantage of
their time off during the pandemic and
many people learned new skills they did
online classes etc and so their market
value has improved but if they don't
find a job that matches their skill
improvement maybe they're just going to
decide to hold out
number four commuting uh people many
times just don't want to go back to
commuting obviously during the beginning
phase of the pandemic many workers moved
out of the areas that would be hiring by
now like they moved from cities to rural
areas and they just have decided they
don't want to commute anymore that's
been my experience like i like working
from home it wouldn't be a total deal
breaker for me if i had to start going
back into an office every day but i'd
prefer to just keep working from home
obviously commuting can be very very
stressful especially if you have a long
commute like if you're driving an hour
to and from work every day i mean that's
just crazy and if you don't have to do
it anymore why would you want to so
commuting obviously is a big factor
number five child care most schools are
open at this point but there can be
cancellations based on coveted cases at
the drop of a hat maybe the school year
gets halted early obviously we're seeing
some closures now with omicron
so sometimes parents who may be working
part time while the kids are at school
they can't do that anymore because they
have to be home to take care of the
child or at least they have to keep that
as an option in case school does get
shut down number six is protests over
vaccine mandates there are some people
who are just not going to get the
vaccine no matter what it doesn't matter
if you offer them a carrot or a stick
and so obviously if they refuse to get
the vaccine there are so many jobs that
they're no longer eligible for they
can't work for a government agency or
they can't be a government contractor
they can't work for a company with more
than 50 employees they can't work in
certain cities in the country so
obviously that lowers their
possibilities when it comes to the job
market and that's also contributing in
part to the labor shortage number seven
fear of the virus cases are obviously
surging out of control right now the
omicron variant is super contagious and
so there are people who are maybe older
or immuno-suppressed and they feel as
though you know i want to get a job but
i don't want to put my life at risk by
doing so and number eight the great
resignation this is a term coined by
organizational psychologist anthony
klotz who theorizes that people
especially pre-pandemic they would tie
in their identity with their work and
now with people taking some time off and
really being confronted with their
mortality because the amount of people
who have died over the past couple of
years it's caused a shift in their
perspective and they no longer wrap up
their identity with what they do as a
job and i think that you know maybe the
great resignation talking point is a
little bit overblown because after all
people need to work to survive most
people do anyway
uh but you know there could be some
people who decide i'm not going to work
40 to 50 hours a week anymore i'm going
to work part time or maybe i'll take a
few more years off and resume working
later maybe i want to decide that i'm
going to do something else with my life
so it's definitely a mix of factors some
of these things you're going to be able
to improve over time other things you
may not be able to like for example the
baby boomers retiring early are you
really going to be able to bring them
back into the job market probably not
they're probably retired and not going
to be entering the job force again at
least not in mass but then there's other
factors that will improve as the state
of coronavirus in this country improves
as we finally see cases go down we
finally start to see deaths go down
whenever that may be the economy will
follow we've been saying this for two
years now that you have to deal with the
virus before you can deal with the
economy and we'll hope that this all
sort of sorts itself out but that's the
sort of update now having to do with the
labor shortage and many of the reasons
why it's happening
follow the david pakman show on social
media interact with me and other david
pakman show viewers you'll be able to
see when we're taking calls live on the
show we post hilarious video clips
you'll see exclusive show content not on
the show and you'll be the first to see
big announcements like upcoming guests
and more follow me on twitter at dpakman
and davidpakmanshow we're on instagram
david.pakman join the reddit community
at davidpakman.com
reddit and you can also find the david
pakman show on facebook discord and tick
tock it's almost too easy welcome back
to the show so former trump strategist
steve bannon when he's not fighting off
criminal charges for a build the wall
money laundering scheme or fighting off
charges for contempt of congress having
to do with the january 6th capital riots
he hosts a tv and radio show on real
america's voice called the war room
wherein he tries to build up an audience
of trump supporters and his thing is to
really appeal to the gung-ho ones the
ones who believe that trump is the
savior and trump really won the 2020
election but if he was of course robbed
by joe biden and the democrats and voter
fraud and all this nonsense now i think
that steve bannon is an obvious grifter
he pretends to be one of these
anti-establishment anti-elitist folks
when at the same time he has degrees
from georgetown and harvard and he used
to work at goldman sachs and in
hollywood but his thing is to scam
die-hard trump supporters into thinking
that he's one of them right he's a true
working-class american kind of guy and
sometimes he quite literally scams
people if you look at that money
laundering scheme that he allegedly did
well bannon is always trying to build up
some media attention always trying to
make a headline and some recognition for
himself and he's done it yet again this
time by supporting fox host jesse waters
in his time of need now waters as we
talked about on the show this week he
went to a tpusa conference called
america fest and
waters used this strong rhetoric against
dr anthony fauci implying without
directly saying that people should hunt
down fauci and kill him water said stuff
like boom he is dead ambush and kill
shot now waters was speaking
metaphorically of course but it's clear
what he was doing and it's incredibly
irresponsible given the fact that fauci
and his family have received a
tremendous amount of death threats over
the past couple of years mainly from
trump supporters and he's obviously
worried for his safety he's worried
about some crazy trump supporter
attacking him so waters words definitely
add some fuel to the fire there and
fauci followed up by saying that fox
should fire jessie waters for his
comments but of course fox news is not
going to do that they're going to stick
by their guy uh farron talked about this
story earlier this week if you want to
check that clip out but now steve bannon
is getting in on the fun he's piling on
and he can see that jesse waters got
some attention from all this and now
bannon wants to share in some of that
spotlight i'd imagine that bannon no
longer wants to be relegated to the
likes of real america's voice and he
wants to be now a fox news host or he
wants some sort of prime time radio job
or something like that so let's take a
look at what uh steve bannon had to say
uh his his perspective on this
controversy and then we'll follow up on
the other end
look at jesse waters great jesse water
sitting up there exactly what you're
doing vouching mr ricks i've only told
everybody it's about you funding the
chinese communist party pla lab you liar
you're going to be held accountable and
your buddy your partner collins with it
carlin's collins can run away he's
leaving
we're getting him and we're getting you
you're gonna be held accountable and
responsible for what you've done
tony
short commercial break we'll be back
with daryn beatty ben harnwell so he
says that jesse waters is a great guy
and he says that we're getting you
having to do with anthony fauci all of
this aggressive stuff with the religious
christmas music going on in the
background that really was quite the
contrast there i have to say and
obviously these threats don't amount to
what you would need for criminal charges
or anything like that nor should they
this definitely falls under free speech
because they are veiled threats after
all but you always have to be on the
lookout for a stochastic terrorism event
there is a real possibility that someone
in waters audience or bannon's audience
they could hear these words the ambush
comment kill shot we're getting you etc
and decide that these are calls to
action and they could decide to take
action into their own hands and carry
out something really egregious against
anthony fauci over them
and we've seen it happen before with
different people we've seen it with
members of glenn beck's audience we've
seen it with bill o'reilly's audience if
you have an audience of thousands of
people or millions of people
and they watch you every day and they
believe what you say
there's a chance that maybe just one
person can really take those words to
heart and maybe they're not the most
mentally stable and they decide that
they're going to
view it as a call to action and they
could go out and kill someone because of
the words that you said there and so you
have a responsibility to your audience
and society more broadly not to be doing
that stuff and not to be speaking so
recklessly and just the final point
because bannon is now making a career
off of sucking up to donald trump acting
like this big pro-trump guy and uh you
know trying to appeal to his supporters
did everyone forget that donald trump
turned on this guy a while ago like not
only did trump fire steve bannon after
the charlottesville incident for being
toxic he also released the following
statement about him after it came out
that michael wolff used steve bannon as
a source for the book fire and fury
quote michael wolff is a total loser who
made up stories in order to sell this
really boring and untruthful book he
used sloppy steve bannon who cried when
he got fired and begged for his job now
sloppy steve has been dumped like a dog
by almost everyone too bad so this is
steve bannon's life now i guess he has
to make a living off of sucking up to
trump who fired him and publicly
ridiculed him he has to try to appeal to
the lowest common denominator of trump
supporters and reassure them all of
their worldview it's pathetic stuff but
that's exactly who steve bannon is over
the years we've seen plenty of
right-wing politicians sully whatever
credibility they had left trying to get
into the good graces of donald trump and
oftentimes it ends up just completely
backfiring or they get into trouble over
it and the next person to be following
this trend appears to be trump's fourth
and final white house chief of staff
mark meadows and that is because meadows
is no longer cooperating with the
january 6th congressional committee
meaning that if his abstinence continues
charges could indeed be coming his way
now as recently as a few weeks ago
meadows was cooperating with the january
6th committee he was providing them with
documents and really naming names like
the whole reason we know about the story
having to do with sean hannity and brian
kilmeade and laura ingram urging
meadows to tell trump to end the
insurrection was because meadows was
willing to hand over the documents he
was willing to hand over those text
messages to the committee obviously we
also found out that don jr was trying to
urge meadows to put an end to it and we
also found out that congressman jim
jordan was
giving an outline to meadows as to how
mike pence could throw out the electoral
college votes in states that they were
contesting so this is all based on the
fact that meadows was complying with the
committee's requests and handing over
the documents but everything changed
around the time meadows released his
book the chief's chief and trump
publicly lambasted meadows for the claim
specifically that trump exposed people
to covid after he tested positive for
the virus
and one of those people that he exposed
was actually joe biden during their
first debate trump called the allegation
fake news and meadows backtrack saying
oh yeah that part of my book that was
fake news apparently regretting that he
upset his former boss meadows thought
that the book was going to flatter trump
and instead it mainly just got under his
skin because of the media coverage
having to do with that positive test it
did the exact opposite of what he was
trying to do it was right after this
incident that meadows halted his
communications with the january 6th
committee the january 6 commission
wanted to get meadows to show up in
person for testimony meadows lawyer
george terewillager argued he had done
enough he had provided the documents and
the committee should be satisfied with
that in fact tara willager released a
statement that reads quote the select
committee's true intentions in dealing
with mr meadows have been revealed when
it accuses him of contempt citing the
very documents his cooperation has
produced so what mark meadow's attorney
is saying here is that basically you
should be grateful to my client because
so much of this information that you
have now is because he was willing to
cooperate with the investigation you
shouldn't be turning around now and
trying to rope him into testifying if he
doesn't want to you shouldn't be
threatening him with criminal charges
because you know he's given you so much
already and it is true that mark meadows
was fully cooperating and handed over uh
9 000 pages of documents even though
some of that information was indeed
damaging to meadows and to the former
president he still did do that but you
don't really get partial credit when
you're talking about a select committee
that has the rule of law behind them and
if you're not going to do everything
that they ask of you then you're going
to open yourself up to criminal exposure
and that's exactly what's happened here
recently the house voted to refer mark
meadows for criminal contempt of
congress charges and it's going to be up
to biden's justice department and
attorney general merrick garland to
decide whether or not he's actually
going to be charged and if he is and
he's found guilty there's actually the
possibility on the table of mark meadows
serving prison time over this now is
that actually going to happen i don't
know he may not even get charged in the
first place because it's going to be
seen as an overtly political act if this
happens like yes bannon was charged in
this investigation but he also wasn't
willing to comply at all
and bannon was in trump's administration
but only as an advisor whereas mark
meadows like he was the chief of staff
after all it's a much more important gig
and so maybe they would just figure that
biden and biden's justice department
wouldn't have the political capital to
charge mark menos for his abstinence in
this case but we'll have to wait and see
and then obviously if he does get
charged that doesn't mean necessarily
he'll get convicted and if he does get
convicted that doesn't mean necessarily
that he'll go to prison over it he may
just face a fine or something like that
so we'll have to wait and see what
happens but you never know like
this could definitely happen and there's
definitely some legal exposure here and
meadows i'm sure is probably not
sleeping very well at night
these days and that's all because of
donald trump and he was trying to get on
trump's good side and now at the end of
the day he's not only on trump's bad
side
he's also
running the risk of criminal charges so
that's mark meadows for you and now
there's this very very long list of
people who went down for donald trump's
sake you already thought it was long
enough well it's getting even longer we
have people on there like roger stone
steve bannon paul manafort michael flynn
rick gates george papadopoulos michael
cohen we know that rudy giuliani of
course is in trouble he's under
investigation and he's also facing that
civil suit with dominion voting systems
there's people like
mike lindell and sydney powell who are
also running against that case with
dominion voting systems so is mark
meadows the next to follow the next to
get in trouble trying to get into the
good graces of donald trump we'll just
have to wait and see but you'd think
that all these people would learn their
lesson by now
on the bonus show today we have some
great stories we're going to talk about
how kim potter the former police officer
she has been found guilty in
manslaughter charges having to do with
the the killing of dante wright kim
potter of course was the officer who
confused her service weapon with her
taser and she thought that she was
tasing dante wright but she actually
shot and killed him
she has been found guilty now so we'll
see what happens with sentencing we'll
see the reactions to all of that we're
going to talk about donald trump
declaring victory on the war on
christmas he talked to mike huckabee
about how before trump was president no
one would say merry christmas and you
weren't allowed to but ever since trump
served in office now all of a sudden you
can say merry christmas and i also want
to talk about a recent covet scare that
i had i think many of you will find that
story interesting if you want to watch
the bonus show today go to
joinpakman.com and sign up for a
membership or you can go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow and sign up for a five
dollar membership there that's going to
do it for today that's going to do it
for the week merry christmas to everyone
david will be back next week and we'll
see you then